finally
someone gets it
hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by
squarespace and we'll be taking a look
at fellow intuitive eater victoria
garrick
but first let me tell you about my
sponsor squarespace so if you're not
familiar with squarespace it's an
all-in-one platform to run your business
whether you're looking to build a
website blog online store or use their
marketing tools and analytics so as a
busy dietitian and blogger myself i love
that squarespace has features that allow
you to schedule appointments through an
online calendar and set up email
campaigns for a mailing list it's also
so easy to seamlessly pull content
directly from instagram or twitter when
everything in your digital presence
works together like this it just makes
it so much easier for you to focus on
your actual business so you can check
out squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com
abbysharp to save 10 off of your first
purchase of a website or domain now
before we get into it feel free to pause
the screen or look at the description
for my general disclaimer also if you
are new here welcome friends do not
forget to subscribe to this channel and
ring that little bell so that you never
miss out on a episode
wow i've had a lot of coffee
a bit of a background here victoria
garrick is a former d1 volleyball
athlete who's been very open about her
past struggles with binge eating
disorder she now explicitly calls
herself an intuitive eater and has made
intuitive eating and eating disorder
recovery very much part of her brand she
founded and runs the hidden opponent
which is a non-profit advocacy group
raising awareness for mental health
struggles in student athletes and in
addition to her tick tock instagram and
youtube she also hosts a podcast called
real pod discussing body image and
mental health i am
a mentally a fan so i'm actually going
to do today's video slightly differently
based on what i think would actually be
most helpful as it relates uniquely to
content like victoria's so rather than
breaking this down to focus on the
specific food choices i want to actually
focus on victoria's intuitive eating
process victoria's wedding in a day
videos are very different than basically
anyone else's on youtube in that she
really does make a point of walking you
through her thought process of every
bite to really help you understand what
it's like to intuitively eat so i want
to use victoria's day to really
reinforce that inner dialogue and to
help you understand what you might
experience if you two are learning to
intuitively eat all right let's take a
look at what victoria and her best
friend eat on a little girl's ski
getaway
okay how's the food treating you oh good
i'm gonna finish school yeah the spoon
the spoon is rather large i've taken way
too much i get so over eager with yogurt
okay so first of all i just need to say
and i'm sure she hears this all the time
but she looks so so so much like alicia
silverstone circa 1995.
[Applause]
but anyways back to the food this looks
delicious and we've got some really
great balance going on here too so we've
got some protein and fat in the yogurt
fiber in the berries and granola and
seeing as they're off for morning to ski
i think this is a really great
energizing choice that also sounds like
she enjoys as well now i noticed in this
section of the video she never says
anything like oh i should choose the
yogurt and granola instead of the bagel
or bacon or french toast or pancakes or
whatever this just seems like it's
genuinely what she's feeling like today
when do we predict we'll eat next 12 30.
really no we'll eat when our bodies are
ready to eat yes clean
okay so i love that victoria's bestie
has clearly been listening to victoria
talk about intuitive eating on her
channels or like every day in real life
so yes obviously intuitive eating means
that if you are hungry you don't need to
hold off for some predetermined time or
like a fasting window before you are
allowed to eat having said that i also
think that it can be very stressful and
in some cases unproductive for people to
not have
some kind of loose plan or structure in
their day if being 100 spontaneous on
meals and snacks works for you amazing
this is personally how i eat on like
weekends or on holidays when i literally
have no hard set plans and then my hubs
and i just kind of look at each other
and we're like hey you hungry like what
do you feel like so this also makes some
sense for this little girl's weekend
getaway trip like this but during the
work week maybe you're working or you've
got kids having a rough reliable
schedule for some people may actually
help us think less obsessively about
food and eating particularly for those
actual sit-down meals and when i say
rough i mean like if your lunch break is
typically at noon but you're super
hungry at 11 45 then yes like you should
totally pop a few nuts in your mouth to
get you through
that's what she said
but it's also okay
to experience some hunger between meals
that sensation can actually help us
recognize satiety and be able to
effectively collect data about what meal
or snack timing feels best to us and
also which foods actually satisfy bats
so if you actually do need some
structure i like to have a rough
timeline for the main meals in my day
and then if i get really hungry before
that and i find that you know my hunger
is impacting my ability to work or
concentrate or just get stuff done then
i will have a snack to get me to that
next meal chicken tenders and fries i
was just really craving this i did want
to get some sort of vegetable but the
salads were like 17 dollars so it's not
worth it
and i asked for two rolls because that's
what i needed today okay so for lunch
let's remember that we are out on
vacation and eating out so we are going
to be eating differently than maybe we
would at home so she was craving the
chicken tenders and fries while her best
friend actually said she had the chicken
tenders the day before and didn't feel
so great so she opted for a bowl of
chili with two roles because one didn't
feel like it would be enough i love that
her friend had collected some solid data
about her previous eating experience and
also about her current level of hunger
to inform her meal choice today but just
to focus back on victoria here i like
that we've got some protein and fat in
the chicken and maybe a little bit of
fiber and fries victoria did acknowledge
that she would have liked to have some
vegetable with it but the salads there
were like crazy expensive 17 bucks like
we need some like better regulation
around that am i right and obviously
from like a gentle nutrition perspective
i agree
like my tip would be to add in a source
of veggies or even a piece or two of
fruit but sometimes like particularly
when you're eating out or you're on a
budget
these things are just not accessible i
get asked about intuitive eating on a
budget or at a school meal plan like
this all the time and my response here
is that part of intuitive eating is
about being okay with imperfection and
being able to accept that not every meal
is going to be perfectly balanced you
kind of have to work with what you got
and i think it's amazing evidence of a
good relationship with food that
victoria doesn't freak out about this
she wasn't like oh my god the healthy
option is not available to me my whole
day is blown my disappointment is
immeasurable and my day is ruined now
i'm gonna have to eat just like steamed
vegetables for dinner etc she was able
to be like
yeah you know a little salad action
probably would have felt better to me
but it didn't financially make sense and
my body is smart enough that this meal
is not gonna break my health bank so
even though this isn't the most
nutritious meal
this is normal eating especially for a
getaway day with friends so friends
followers
take note okay i'm done this is what is
remaining on my plate i just want to
interject here i want people to know
that you're not doing intuitive eating
wrong or failing if you finish
everything that's on your plate it's
still hard for me sometimes not to
finish what's on my plate mainly out of
long-term habit or convenience or the
fact that i'm a mom now and i often feel
like being able to sit down to like a
full satisfying meal is a bit more
unpredictable i do usually leave food on
my plate or like pack it up as leftovers
when eating out like this or if i'm at
like a buffet and i'm trying a bunch of
things and i don't like love some of the
things that i put on my plate but if i
serve myself a meal at home
i generally do have a better sense ahead
of time of what i feel like and how much
so i find what works best for me at home
is to serve myself like a modest portion
and then i go back in for more to
minimize the food waste i do the same
thing with my kids small portions first
then add to them but i'm just bringing
this up because i don't want people to
feel like they need to force themselves
to leave one fry or like one bite of
chicken
on their plate in the name of food
freedom if you want to finish the last
fry finish the last fry what good does
it do you to be thinking about that fry
all day true food freedom or intuitive
eating is all about minimizing guilt and
shame period including any guilt
associated with not doing intuitive
eating right folks there is no right
i'll be honest i don't feel like a
million bucks after eating that but i'm
really full it's nothing to do with oh i
felt bad because i had chicken tenders
and fries it's not about the food it's
literally feeling like she felt
not great after eating this food you
should have warned me about the
attendees i'm sorry it's okay to
encroach i know and also like i probably
would have gone for it anyways because i
needed to experience it myself yes and
this is what intuitive eating will help
guide you on this is what i'm talking
about when i say
data collection you know like you eat a
meal that you crave and you see how it
makes you feel and her friend said she
also had the chicken tenders the day
before and was kind of also left feeling
a bit sluggish after
so she let that experience guide her new
choice today and then later on in the
video i love that victoria straight up
said yeah
even if you had warned me about the
chicken tenders making you feel kind of
crappy i wouldn't have listened because
i needed to experience it myself i
100 agree different foods are going to
feel different to different people
this is why just listening to an
influencer on tick-tock tell you that
like eating processed oils are going to
make you sick or fatigued or whatever
doesn't make you truly want to
completely avoid process oils for life
it might scare you a bit into avoiding
them but it doesn't eliminate that
deep-seated curiosity
you need to own your data and own your
experience and i like that she's
reiterating and clarifying that this
isn't a moral i don't feel good because
my choice was an unhealthy choice this
is a i didn't really eat any fiber or
vegetables and this meal was probably a
little high in salt so now i'm in italy
feeling like a little fogged out and
bloated and fatigued see the distinction
very important distinction and yes
certain foods or food combinations can
make you feel a little bit less
energetic which is why most of the time
a balanced plate is what's going to feel
best but knowing this or not knowing
this while choosing the chicken finger
and fry combo anyway
doesn't mean you're automatically
unhealthy or that your choices were
inherently bad it's just data that
you've collected to inform another
delicious day i know this sounds kind of
weird but i kind of want some skittle to
like wash out the taste of the teddy
does that make sense
this is sparking new life in me okay i
want a few more
okay so nutrition wise
even if i wanted to kind of liven myself
up after a meal like the chicken tenders
and fries where the dominant flavor is
like i don't know
salt i would probably intuitively reach
for something fiber-rich sprightly and
refreshing so for example maybe some
really tangy juicy fruit or like crisp
vegetables and some dip but again
we know that victoria's access to
veggies in the scenario is limited so
it's super interesting to me that her
intuition said hey you know those
skittles might actually just liven up
the palette and i actually think that's
really insightful skittles have the same
tangy sweet juicy flavor that stimulates
the salvatory mechanisms in the mouth
the same way that a big bowl of juicy
tangy mango or pineapple would so even
though it's probably not going to fix
the blah feeling she's experiencing in
her belly or her energy levels since
skittles are like a naked simple carb it
may temporarily alleviate the bleh
feeling she's experiencing in her mouth
and again that is a valid need and
instinct to respond to an honor as well
she did only eat like three not the
whole bag so i wouldn't expect that
really would contribute to significantly
to her current state of black
but
if she had eaten the whole bag after her
chicken and fries it would have just
been more data for her to collect to be
like oh boy you know maybe
maybe some protein or fiber in that
snack would have felt better and maybe
would have prevented the pre-dinner kind
of
energy crash so as a gentle nutrition
tip if you're craving something like
skittles or another naked carb one great
way to honor that craving without
dipping into scarcity mentality is to
make it a hunger crushing combo so maybe
having some nuts or seeds with those
skittles would really help to stabilize
and iron out the blood sugar response so
we are back from dinner so for the
appetizer we had a caesar salad and we
had pasta i forgot to film that so this
is some footage of my um empty plate
then for dinner we had trout it was the
first time i ever had trout it came it
was delicious and then i got dessert um
i got this really delicious like three
ice cream layer cookie cake we had the
w-i-n-e okay so this meal she just
described sounds like heaven
and also pretty well balanced like we've
got some protein and healthy omega-3
rich fats in the trout we got carbs and
fiber in the pasta we got a little
veggies and also some fat in the caesar
salad and also the most epic sounding
cake i have ever heard of now is caesar
salad the most nutrient dense salad no
like there's very little fiber in
romaine lettuce compared to like a
hardier green like kale or chopped salad
that's got lots of other veggies in
there but again the girl is on vacation
and it sounds like it was an italian
restaurant so if that's what sounded
good to her or that's what was available
to her
it works i
love me a good garlicky caesar myself
now i also get the sense from watching a
lot of victoria's videos that she
doesn't eat like this every single day
so
some days i've seen her have a chicken
spinach salad other days it's nutella on
toast with berries and fruit and others
it's like a homemade chicken and rice
bowl she likely doesn't get to go out
for a ski trip with a girlfriend and
have wine and cake every day but what i
loved most about this meal is that it
sounded like the highlight was actually
the most nutrient dense part the fish
let's take a listen how are you feeling
about this day of food like oh my god
well honestly like after that trout i'm
like i never want to eat anything but
fish again
i feel amazing okay so i can't speak for
victoria but when i was struggling with
disordered eating if i had allowed
myself a meal that included cake pasta
caesar salad with full fat dressing and
wine
i probably wouldn't touch something
healthy like fish if i was in like
full-blown cheat day or binge mode i was
going to order all the foods that i
otherwise wouldn't allow myself to have
i wasn't gonna like waste space in my
stomach eating something safe and
healthy that i would just be forcing
myself to eat on the regular anyway but
you can see that with victoria and also
her friend who seems to have a really
solid healthy relationship with food as
well these women are able to appreciate
the inherent deliciousness of naturally
nourishing foods like trout that's what
happens when you stop putting like
refined carbohydrates on this forbidden
yet so alluring pedestal they just
become
another food and all foods become
morally equal and pleasure promoting and
i'm just gonna be totes honest right now
with you guys i am feeling v bloated i
posted earlier this week about being on
my period and being bloated and honestly
you guys when this happens i just really
try to embrace it like
this is my stomach this is how it is
today it's ever changing and my thought
process is just to try not to get super
obsessed and down about it but instead
just be like
well
we're bloated today okay so victoria has
given us some beautiful and truly
helpful mantras for those days when
maybe we're not feeling our best
i don't feel very good
whether it's because we over ate it's
that time of the month we've gained
legitimate weight whatever
just because you practice intuitive
eating and you aren't trying to actively
lose weight doesn't mean that you love
your body or how it looks 24 7. it would
be a complete lie if i suggested that i
never had days where i looked in the
mirror at my belly and felt
self-conscious but i have worked really
hard on the skill of body acceptance it
doesn't have to be body love but i think
that you know acceptance and respect is
a lot more attainable for most folks so
it's like saying
this is what my body looks like today
it's just a tummy it's just fat and
water and my uterus and digestive organs
how it looks doesn't depict my worth or
value and regardless of how far out my
stomach sticks it's capable of so many
amazing things including the fact for me
that has grown and housed and fed two
beautiful boys i've really had to lean
into this myself as i go through this
digestion sibo journey because there are
days when i legit look six months
pregnant again and that can be really
hard so just a reminder to try to be
kind and patient and most of all
accepting this is my body today
and it doesn't need to be changed now i
have watched a lot of victoria's channel
and i follow her closely on tik tok as
well and i have to say
that i think she is one of the most
helpful content creators out there when
it comes to rejecting diet mentality but
one of the questions i anticipate
getting from you who maybe watch some of
her videos is whether or not intuitive
eating involves what seems to be
a lot of work like
a lot of introspection a lot of
constantly checking in and asking
yourself am i hungry now am i full now
what do i crave what do i want how does
this sound how does this make me feel
etc i mean there are videos of victoria
literally walking you step by step
through her thoughts as she does
something as mundane as eating a burrito
and in one video i watched with her
boyfriend she like asks him after every
meal like how do you feel do you feel
satisfied with your choice are you
hungry still etc so is this what
intuitive eating really entails not
necessarily no as i alluded to earlier
intuitive eating isn't like other diets
that have these predetermined sets of
one-size-fits-all rules it's ultimately
a mind-body eating framework informed by
a set of principles but when you come
from a restrictive background
where you're very much used to
scrutinizing every eating episode from a
place of fear guilt or distrust you're
very likely going to need to do a lot
more of that checking in so that you can
get back in touch with your intuition
but over time the inner dialogue becomes
well
more intuitive
you've collected most of the data you
know your body and the need for more
intentional data updates are not as
constant and also like not as intrusive
i guess it's like what that calorie
counting ballerina said
it just can run in the background
except it actually can just run in the
background because you don't have to get
your scale out to weigh your corn flakes
so i do think victoria is more vocal
about her inner dialogue because she's
kind of using it as a teaching tool for
you but i doubt that this is taking up
as much mental space as it may seem it
might i mean her brain is not my brain
[Applause]
but i'm just saying that that's been my
experience anyway so if you are ready to
reject the diet mentality and are
looking for a great step-by-step
real-life tutorial on how to do it i
highly recommend checking out victoria's
content and i also hope that my
commentary on victoria's intuitive
eating commentary was helpful and
reinforcing and on that note that is all
that i have for you guys today thank you
again to squarespace for sponsoring this
video if you liked it be sure to give it
the thumbs up leave me a comment below
on who you'd like to see me review next
subscribe to the channel and i'll see
you next time on abby's kitchen bye